in Ecuador people living in the Amazon
often maintain household gardens called
chakras within the rainforest for
Quechua people who are indigenous to
this part of the Amazon chakras are
often their main source of food Cecilia
she Guangzhou and her family are among
those who live from the bounty and
biodiversity of the forest they know
which plants are good to eat and which
can be used as medicine this fruit is
good for treating snakebite we break
open the skin and squeeze out the juice
onto the wound this wealth of knowledge
is passed down from generation to
generation why you say is another
medicinal plant we give it to women who
are about to give birth it prevents
hemorrhaging now I saw the leaves to
restaurants you can make tea with them
sometimes I get an order and said Ye so
leaves taquito
Casa Grande latina is one of the best
restaurants in the capital recently the
menu has been beefed up with exotic
ingredients from the chakras an
interesting move given the guests are
city dwellers and foreign visitors with
little or no contact with indigenous
communities head chef and the Restless
creates exquisite dishes that embody a
fusion of traditions Western and
indigenous he buys herbes yucca and a
freshwater fish Tai Chi from chakra
farmers in the forest
for high-end restaurants in Ecuador
ingredients brought in from the
rainforests have become something of a
trend
that it's our duty to make these
products more widely known Ecuador may
be a small country but it's home to the
diverse range of species we use foods
from the Amazon the coast the Andes and
the Galapagos Islands our food is a way
to present Ecuador to the outside world
the meals for Celia she Guangzhou cooks
are less elaborate many Quechua
communities are very poor the
livelihoods of indigenous people who
live in the rainforest are in jeopardy
as more and more trees are felled for
the most part chakras are used for
subsistence farming now there are new
opportunities to sell produce to
outsiders there are hardly any jobs
around here sometimes we get work on a
Hacienda rich people pay us just eight
dollars a day to slave away from dawn
till dusk it's a very small amount
that's why our women try to sell things
at the market that market is held every
Sunday in the town nearby
but Kichwa stallholders don't always
sell much
[Applause]
estefania Balian works with a canopy
bridge NGO it helps indigenous farmers
sell directly to restaurants in Quito
chefs in the city use products from the
Amazon in a new and different way the
harvest is now more financially valuable
and people here can earn a little money
some things just don't sell locally even
though they're very healthy and tasty
and have great potential
for Marta Echevarria chanted auras have
proved to be a delicious surprise they
come from the peach palm and have a
nutty flavor when they're roasted she's
one of the founders of canopy bridge the
NGO has now established a supply chain
to 15 restaurants in Quito we can move
people speak to their hearts by
encouraging them to consume products
from the Amazon they should not only
associate the region with deforestation
but also with its cuisine its cultures
and its colors food offers a special way
of relating to a place most people don't
appreciate the immense value of the
Amazon even in Ecuador many people don't
know anything about it so far about 300
indigenous families in the Amazon work
with canopy bridge
the team that wants to support
traditional farming in the forest to
help pitch our people there thrive so
they're not tempted to cut down more
trees in chakras farming is in harmony
with the plants and the animals when
people give up tending their gardens
they start to fell trees and sell them
or turn the forest into grazing land the
forest is rich in fruits and herbs and
tasty fat beetle larvae as well Champa
kudos for Kichwa they're a delicacy full
of fat and protein to be eaten raw or
grilled they live in Shanta trees janta
chorus are not on the menu at fine
restaurants in Quito
at least not yet
you